[Musique]
vous présentez a la pregunta de vidéo
Antionette numériquement chaque personne juste les
économistes anticuchos sont le budeau
Isabel polygone
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien et vous devriez dix je t'aime je t'aime
una pluma nous avons un  point commun
Iridessa attends là-bas un test à l'aveugle
deux petits tests cérébraux pour travailler
plus vu des ravages sur ma topographie sur le rocher
l'intérieur de la cabine musique moi
bébé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
J'ai tellement de vie qui court pour mon
face à
apprendre à louer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ricocher loin du smash
[Applaudissements]
ou père
[Musique]